mark
showed up at a social center um in
nottingham where i was living he started
coming to
campaign meetings
there and he started coming to the bar
in the cafe and
each other and we we got into a
relationship
and unbeknown to you he was actually an
undercover officer who was there to
place you and
people you knew under surveillance
because you were an environmental
activist
did you have any indication whatsoever
so mark i mean what what the the ruling
today the the investigatory powers
tribunal has said mark was sent in to
the community center on what was
basically a fishing expedition
um so he was there just
meeting people and hoovering out
intelligence about everybody and anybody
who was involved in protest activities
there
um
i didn't know that i thought that he was
my friend and my lover
and later my housemate um he
he was he was very very deeply involved
in our lives for seven years
and kate it wasn't until five years
later
that you discovered he was actually an
undercover police officer how did you
discover this
so after mark and i separated he began a
relationship with a close friend of mine
which lasted for six years
she's known as lisa
in the public inquiry and she discovered
his identity so so
[Music]
that's how i found out was through
through her
uncovering the truth and kate the
tribunal found that the mets claims that
undercover officers knew sexual
relationships were banned were
materially undermined by the sheer
frequency with which the man in question
in your case did conduct sexual
relationships with either questions
being asked without either questions
being asked or action being taken by
senior officers we are driven to the
conclusion that either senior officers
were quite extraordinarily naive totally
unquestioning or chose to turn a blind
eye to conduct which was certainly in
the case of
mark that you refer to useful to the
operation and we're hearing about that
today in the case of sarah everard and
the man that's been convicted of her
murder is the police themselves turning
a blind eye to conduct that seemed
seems low-level crime if you like
the
the police have in in this case they've
tried all along to say this was a rogue
officer this was a bad apple and
it's not the there's a large number of
metropolitan police officers serving
undercover officers who have deceived
women into
uh relationships and
uh i think there's 27 women in the um
policing inquiry because they have
relationships with undercover police and
it's the same attitude of trying to
avoid
accountability and not taking seriously
the fact that there are sexual predators
within their ranks and it
the tribunal has ruled that
the senior officers
knew about these relationships and
adopted an approach of don't ask don't
tell because
it was useful to the operations and
that the metropolitan police showed a
worrying lack of concern for the impact
of
these abuses on the women who they put
out yeah kate you were deceived and you
entered into a relationship without
knowing the full facts about someone you
were in a relationship with and you
found out in 2010 we're now in 2021
you've won this landmark case you know
you're a pioneer in that sense tell me
what you've had to fight against to get
to this point because as you said the
police haven't in this case taken it
seriously and as the tribunal said they
sort of turned a blind eye
because it helped operations
so
in some senses i am a pioneer um i
[Music]
didn't start this case alone there were
eight women brought the original case
like i say there's another 27 women now
fighting on these issues in the
undercover policing inquiry
um but it goes even broader than that
because the findings of the tribunal
also talk about the police
lack of concern for collateral intrusion
into the lives of
people that their officers are coming
into contact with and
they actually rule that the operations
themselves were unlawful and unnecessary
in a democratic society because they
were basically targeting our rights to
protest
so
yes in some ways i'm a pioneer but there
there is a large
much wider issue it goes far beyond me
and
and it's taken 10 years
yeah 10 years to get to this point
for you to win your case and kate just
finally a word about trust in the police
force it's the big question today
particularly for women
what would you have to say about it
i think i feel that
we had the finding that the police are
an institutional racist
uh the daniel morgan inquiry recently
found the metropolitan police to be
institutionally corrupt the ipt today
has found that the undercover operations
were guilty of sexist discrimination
i feel that the metropolitan police is
an organization beyond redemption i
think there needs to be a fundamental
rethinking
of
the powers that they are given of the
way that they are structured i don't
see that they've made any great progress
with the institutional racism the
institutional production i don't have
any confidence that they're going to
target target the culture of misogyny
that exists within the police
um kate really good to talk to you today
um and congratulations on winning your
cake kate wilson there environmental
activist who won her a case um against
the metropolitan police for breaches of
human rights after entering unknowingly
into a relationship
with an undercover metropolitan police
officer